incroyable aux écrits à la 4è secondes
de la vidéo aux cousy c'est chiant il
est comme avant et hyperactif titouan
les amis aujourd'hui on va parler d'une
histoire paix qui fait pas peur impôts
mais pas comme la dernière fois le dire
david r c'est ce nouveau format de vidéo
vous avez trop plus quand je décortique
un peu instruits dès que je dis juste au
montage un thread futur patron dit allez
on est ici de ce mystère fred je suis
tombé sur un autre fred d'un certain
manuel bâle iii
il a fait son suède en espagnol mais
heureusement pour nous quelqu'un a
traduit tout le thread en anglais
heureusement pour vous quelqu'un ici va
traduire pour vous en français lorsque
mois des fleurs à lisieux au oui cette
fois c'est pas une histoire de d'enfants
morts qui revient mot d'esprit a acquis
en ton appartement non c'est pas quand
la dernière fois là ça parle d'autre
chose c'est une autre thématique ça fait
flipper mais c'est pas pareil donc
normalement vous pourrez dormir cette
nuit la bonne nouvelle
alors l'été dernier en août 2010 cette
manière tu as décide de partir en
vacances quelques jours dans un hôtel
juste à côté de la plage tout était
magnifique là même une petite photo de
l'endroit où il passait ses vacances
c'est merveilleux c'est tout ce qu'on
aime et bientôt vous y serez peut-être
qu'en tout cas je vous le souhaite il
était tranquillement en train de lire
sur la terrasse de sa chambre d'hôtel
lorsque d'un coup ça porte de chambre
souffle quelqu'un porte
inutile de préciser que manuel était en
vacances seul pour décompresser un petit
peu de la vie il était solo alors il se
dit [ __ ] c'est sûrement un quelqu'un
du room service ou qui veut changer les
draps ou quoi et j'ai oublié de mettre
le truc ne pas déranger bon c'est ma
faute mais pas du tout en allant dans sa
chambre il découvre un homme fin et
grands qui arpentent la pièce là ça
commence à faire peur joue la corde
manuel est un peu rassuré parce que le
mec n'a pas l'air agressif il a juste
l'air paumé j'aurais c'est pas oublié du
tout alors manuel s'approche de lui pour
lui parler et laï yu sharp le bras
manuel sursauter le gars m'a lu par les
très très vite mais ce qu'ils disent est
totalement incompréhensible
je n'ai pas vraiment parler de ces
catégories
r j'étais bien là moi j'ai peur dans le
cou fils de [ __ ] de série qui s'activent
tout seul au début manuel pensée qui
parlait dans une autre langue mais petit
à petit se met à reconnaître des mots et
en fait c'est juste que le gars ne
parlait pas avec les mots dans le
bonheur dont on aurait dit qu'ils
appellent un mot sur deux et qui mixait
des phrases c'était très bizarre sa
meilleure part les le mec regard
derrière lui et puis par et manu réalise
que le gars il avait une carte de
chambres d'hôtels dont probablement une
carte qui pouvait ouvrir la chambre de
magnitski est terrifiant il a vraiment
pas envie d inconnues une carte qui
ouvre ta chambre d'hôtel quand à l'hôtel
on est d'accord la manu un réflexe très
humain il verrouille sa porte il se pose
sur le canapé en mode [ __ ] qu'est ce
qui vient de m'arriver c'est choquant
que ça tard il entre comme ça et il
fonce à l'accueil de l'hôtel pour dire
[ __ ] il ya un mec qui a accès à ma
chambre c'est quoi ce bordel
il leur dit qu'à son avis c est
probablement l'ancien locataire de cette
chambre là et qu'ils ont oublié de
rendre inefficace sa carte c'est un
système magnétique que tu pilotes par
ordinateur que tu pilotes je suis vieux
c'est bon c'est officiel l'hôtel ça leur
paraît bizarre quand même c'est pas un
truc que tu oublies ses limites le
premier truc que tu fais quand quelqu'un
fait le check out en partant de l'hôtel
alors il se met à décrire l'armée nous
dit voilà il est grand il est fin il a
des cheveux courts et à maaf de
l'accueil dit à manu de regarder
derrière lui parce que le mec était
juste là en fait donc tout le monde fait
un petit rire nerveux et réinitialise
les cartes comme ça y'a que la chambre
de ma nuque ou la chambre de manu et
c'est très bien comme ça et l'histoire
finit bien pour moment on est bien on
est bien jeu si vous allez dormir ça ne
lui fait pas confiance
manu nous dit aussi qu'un deuxième truc
bizarre qui est arrivé dans la journée
il a perdu un t-shirt voilà c'est fait
chier eux-mêmes petite photo de t-shirts
sais pas si terrible qu'il ait perdu vue
là le t-shirt mais ça c'est les coûts
vestimentaire c'est autre chose c'est
l'après midi manu décent pour manger et
là il voit le fameux mec était entrée
dans sa chambre à quelques tables de
l'ue au réfectoire préfecture au self
suis bloqué au lycée c'est fou parce
qu'ils soient bien compréhensible et
plus sympa raconté on va l'appeler
martin cet homme en passant devant
martin martin le salut et s'excuse
devant lui et cette fois ils parlent
clairement avec chaque mot parfaitement
dans l'ordre contrairement à dans la
chambre en gros il s'excuse d'être aller
dans la mauvaise champ mais s'est trompé
il est dans une autre chambre et ça lui
fait chier d'avoir fait peur à notre ami
manu donc il s'excuse c'est un homme
gentil et le mec il arrête pas dire à
mannus t'inkiet tout va bien avec un
petit sourire bizarre sur son visage il
en fait des caisses le gars est ce petit
sourire ça m'est vraiment mal à l'aise
manuela vellés me de plus peur à ce
moment là que quand le mec est entrée
dans sa chambre manufrance et khouya
demain elle prend une photo de lui de
loin et le gard ressemble à ça
voilà un qui fait peur c'est un mec quoi
c'est vraiment un mec qui a les cheveux
courts était en vacances manuel passe la
matinée sur la plage en rentrant dans sa
chambre il trouve par terre un petit
crayon de papier qui apparemment est un
peu usés c'est à dire qu'on a écrit avec
alors il se dit que c'est sûrement
quelqu'un de l'hôtel qui est venu
changer les draps et qui a fait tomber
ça sans faire exprès mais après ce qui
s'est passé la veille avec notre ami
martin y ce chien peu dessus manu manu
décide alors d'aller marcher et donne
pas nouvelle à voir le soir où il nous
dit qu'il marchait sur la plage et qu'il
a décidé d'aller sur un ponton il ya
toujours plein de gens qui prennent des
photos il décide d'aller au bout du
ponton et en regardant derrière lui
qu'est ce qu'ils voient des gens parmi
lesquels se trouve martin on voit pas
clairement à cause du contre-jour mais
manu nous dit qu'il est certain que
c'était martin avec un autre homme qui
était en train de l'observer ces glands
qui décide alors d'aller les voir et au
moment où il se met à marcher vers eux
font demi-tour et partent lui fait le
plus peur c'est que l'homme qui
accompagne et martin y porter le t-shirt
que manu a perdu la veille il avait donc
aucun style puisque ce t-shirt est
dégueulasse il revient nous donne des
nouvelles en nous disant que il trouve
qu'il a un peu paniqué que ça se trouve
martin s'était pas du tout l'un des deux
mecs qui étaient sur le pont que l'autre
c'était juste un hasard qu'il est même
t-shirt bref et rationalise le truc
parce que ça fait quatre jours qui lui
est rien arrivé donc ils commencent à
être re un peu en confiance
il décide alors d'aller se détendre en
nageant à la plage et à son retour il
nous dit qu'il s'est passé un truc
il dit qu'en sortant de l'eau il est
tombé sur un mec qui portait le même
t-shirt que celui qu'il a perdu et là
l'impression de reconnaître cette
personne puisqu'il pense que c'est celle
qui accompagnait martin sur le ponton il
décide alors de le prendre en photo à
deux reprises
il finit de manger y paye et quitte le
ba ba nous prend vraiment en filature
notre ami inconnu il le suit jusqu'au
supermarché dans lequel israël a man who
pète un câble et prend une vidéo du mec
et il se trouve que le mec a exactement
la même gueule que manu pour nous aider
ma nuit mais une photo de lui juste
derrière et effectivement c'est
troublant ils se ressemblent énormément
il perd sa trace en sortant du
supermarché et il est vraiment choqué le
manu parce que la zone elle est tout
petit il ya genre un bar un restaurant
en hôtel la plage il n'y a pas grand
chose à faire à côté il nous dit que ce
mec-là sa journée c'était aller à la
plage juste derrière on l'a vu il a
commandé un burger et un soda et juste
derrière il est allé acheter de l'eau un
supermarché et ce qui a énormément
stressé manu tu sais que c'est
exactement ce que manu a fait le premier
jour ils arrivés là dans le même ordre
manu rentrer à l'hôtel il ya cette
histoire de crime papy qui le stresse il
a retrouvé sa au milieu de sa salle de
bain il sait toujours pas ce que ça
foutait là qui l'a mis là alors la nuit
se met à chercher
où le gars aurait pu écrire et il trouve
[Applaudissements]
alors sur du pq oui c'est drôle sauf que
manu et rigole pas trop parce que ça
monte qui a vraiment quelqu'un qui est
venu dans sa chambre mais qui a marqué
un [ __ ] de truc et manu dit un truc
très vrai il dit si quelqu'un voulait me
dire quelque chose et qui voulait
quelques mois qu'ils lisent ya aucun
meilleur endroit que marquer ça dans le
rouleau de pq mais c'est vrai alors manu
déroule complètement le rouleau au cas
où et s'aperçoit qu'il ya des mots
marquer sur chaque feuille il place les
mots dans un ordre qui veut dire à peu
près quelque chose selon lui mais il
demande de l'aide aux gens parce que
c'est bizarre ça lui rappelle la manière
dont le gars qui venait dans sa chambre
lui a parlé alors sa communauté l'aide à
résoudre ce [ __ ] de mystère du pq et
même si à des mots qui peuvent être
changées sa garde du sens globalement la
phrase c'est ça tu es en danger il n'y a
plus aucun espoir pour moi mais tu peux
encore te sauver va dans l'autre chambre
et ne la quitte plus ce n'est pas une
blague
[ __ ] le coup de pression sa mère le
message c'est vraiment un [ __ ]
d'avertissement alors ça le stress parce
que dans le meilleur des cas c'est une
prend que très élaboré d'un mec et c'est
très tôt médecins de dire [ __ ]
quelqu'un entrer dans ma chambre et a
écrit ça pour me pour me faire peur de
me faire un canular ou alors c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui veut m'avertir
d'un truc et c'est encore pire donc
notre manu là il est en pls vraiment
manu se met alors à penser qu'il ya deux
martin pourquoi il pense ça alors que
c'est la même personne physiquement
parce qu'elle parlait tellement
différemment quand il a vu dans sa
chambre par rapport à quand il a vu au
breakfast qu'il est convaincu que c'est
pas la même personne sachant mettant 328
il se dit que la seule autre chambre
qu'on peut faire avec les numéros 3 2 et
8 ce serait la chambre 238 c'est la
seule possibilité puisque dans l'hôtel
n'y a pas de chambres huit cents et
quelques manu prend alors son courage à
deux mains il décide d'appeler cette
chambre est une femme décroche et par
l'emballement à l'eau et il pense alors
que c'est une fausse piste et que ça
doit être une autre chambre dont deux
messages par les manuels va se coucher
le lendemain matin il va se balader
l'après-midi reste dans sa chambre se
reposer repenser à tout ça ça stresse
beaucoup il nous explique que sa chambre
à vue sur l'une des deux piscines de
l'hôtel et il ya un truc flippant et dit
qu'il est convaincu d'avoir vu l'autre
manuelle l'observé depuis la piscine ce
qu'il appelle l'autre manuelle c'est le
mec il a suivi jusqu'au supermarché
plutôt auparavant et qui lui ressemble
énormément il décide de prendre une
vidéo pour nous montrer ça et il prend
soin d'éteindre la lumière de sa chambre
avant pour pas que l'autre manuelle le
voit
[Musique]
sefue banus précipite sur son téléphone
et décide d'appeler l'accueil de l'hôtel
pour les prévenir qu'il ya un mec qui
laisse plein depuis la piscine et que ça
m'inquiète beaucoup après avoir passé le
coup de fil et retourne à sa fenêtre est
là l'autre manu a disparu il est plus
devant la piscine et quelques minutes
plus tard l'accueil de l'hôtel le
rappelle ils lui expliquent qu'ils ont
envoyé quelqu'un pour aller voir et qui
avait personne à côté de la piscine et
qu'il a sûrement fait erreur manu là il
est révolté et décide d'aller leur
montrer la vidéo qu'il a prises pour
leur prouver qu'ils avaient bien
quelqu'un devant la piscine et que c'est
flippant et que c'est pas normal
malheureusement pour lui ça inquiète pas
les mecs de la gueule qui le disque
c'est sûrement le mec qui s'occupe de la
piscine ou quelqu'un de l'hôtel qui
juste se balader bref ils ne prennent
pas du tout au sérieux et manu ça le
rend ouf
à partir de là il n'y a pas de retour en
arrière possible pour manu importe si
c'est une blague ou si c'est réel
il a juste envie de comprendre ce qui se
passe de comprendre ce qui lui arrive ça
le rend dingue et c'est normal et nous
mêmes ce n'était victime de trucs comme
ça on aurait envie d'élucider le mystère
parce que ça rend ouf son hôtel se
trouve à une extrémité de la route manu
a marché jusqu'au bout de cette route
est à l'extrémité de la route se trouve
un hôtel très similaire au sien qui
prend en photo ci est effectivement
c'est carrément la même chose mais à
l'envers c'est comme si chaque hôtel
était le reflet de l'autre on se
croirait dans strangers x bordel en
arrivant à l'accueil de l'hôtel il tombe
sur une femme qui lui parle un petit peu
de la même manière dont martin lui
parler dans le réfectoire manu lui
demande alors si elle est au courant de
l'existence de l'hôtel qui est très
similaire au sien de l'autre côté de la
route et si c'est une chaîne si les
hôtels sont reliés en fait la meuf
esquive vraiment le sujet elle lui dit
juste en fait pas tout va bien un zen on
en vacances manu ça le fait flipper et
décide de rentrer à son hôtel et de
demander à l'accueil s'ils sont courants
que il ya un autre hôtel de l'autre côté
de la route avec une meuf qui est un peu
bizarre à l'accueil les gens d'accueil
répondent qu'ils ont aucune idée de la
possible existence d'un autre hôtel qui
ressemble plus à celui là de l'autre
côté de la route la manui se dit apte
ans à 3 km il devrait totalement savoir
si un autre hôtel alors il monte dans sa
chambre il réfléchit et là il se dit
[ __ ] mais si le message qui me dit
d'aller dans l'otan mais d'y rester
parler de la chambre 328 de cet autre
hôtel de l'autre côté de la route
hélène sorte de déclic le manioc il se
pose au bar de son hôtel et réfléchi et
se dit qu'il va juste y aller
tranquillement toqué attendent que
quelqu'un réponde et demandé des
explications à cette personne sur ce qui
est en train de lui arriver
il y va en tremblant ils l'appréhendent
vraiment ce qui va se passer il arrive
devant l'hôtel et décide de rentrer il
passe l'accueil et il se rend compte que
tout est exactement comme dans son hôtel
à lui sauf que tout est inverse
c'est par exemple pour rejoindre les
chambres il faut forcément passer devant
la piscine hélas la piscine et sur sa
gauche quand il passe devant alors dans
son hôtel à lui allé sur sa droite il
prend l'ascenseur il arrive à l'étagé
music normalement pour aller à sachant
me prend à gauche sauf que la gauche
c'est un cul de sac il doit aller à
droite tout est inversé par rapport à
son hôtel et il se dit [ __ ] qu'est ce
qui se passe ici bordel ce soir la manui
publie une dernière vidéo de quand il
s'approche de la chambre 328 de cet
autre hôtel et ce qui se passe est très
bizarre
à sydney où le moment août à tokyo où tu
as attendu quelqu'un ouvre ta
complètement paniquée elle a une heure
plus tard manu est de retour à son hôtel
et nous dit bon je vais vous expliquer
ce qui s'est passé oui je sais j'ai pété
un câble en arrivant devant la chambre
je sais pages que j'ai foutu mais j'ai
juste testé la carte j'avais une
obsession avec ça et ça a marché la
porte s'est ouverte alors il est rentré
dans la partie nous explique que au
moment où la vidéo coupe
il s'est avancé et tombe face à l'autre
manuelle le mec qui lui ressemble comme
deux gouttes d'eau l'autre manuelle le
regard d'un air énervé commencent à
avancer vers le vrai manuel est le vrai
manuel part en courant parce qu'ils se
chie dessus ces grands morts là il
réalise que c'est chaud que ça va trop
loin ils changent j'ai fait un arrêt
cardiaque dans cette vidéo mais mon gars
chion sur la je vous raconte un truc
terrifiante tout seul dans les bureaux
parce qu il est 21h il ya plus personne
il ya un [ __ ] de rage hyper denner
dehors il pleut à torrent petits chevaux
vers l'import tuera squeeze 2 qui serait
derrière c'est sûr finissons-en mortels
qui se dit ok c'est mort je reste pas
ici plus longtemps il avant son retour
le lendemain manuel valle aéroports et
la personne n'a que de l'aéroport lui
dis bah vous êtes seul parce que vous
avez réservé pour 2 alors qu'il a
réservé tout ça il apprit qu'un billet
alors manu il comprend pas il est confus
et au final il peut prendre l'avion et
rentrer dans l'avion et rentrer chez lui
ou c'est fini liasse et squeeze peut
rentrer chez lui aussi car c'est la fin
hélas non
et ce qui suit est encore pire en
arrivant chez lui le portier lui dis
[ __ ] vous êtes rentré beaucoup plus
tôt que prévu alors vous avez fait vite
et manu comprend pas puisque ça fait une
semaine qu'il est parti alors il lui dit
mais qu'est ce que tu racontes ça fait 7
jours et le portier lui réponds bah non
mais que tu es parti a vraiment quelques
minutes et en plus de ça tu m'as laissé
un petit paquet a donné quand tu
reviendrais alors tiens je te le donne
la manu il comprend rien il prend le
paquet pour lui et bon dans son
appartement il pose ses affaires il
décide d'ouvrir le paquet et il découvre
juste son profil twitter imprimés et en
retournant la feuille et un message qui
marque et qui dit arrête d'écrire tout
ça ça se termine ce soir
tout va bien il se chie dessus alors il
décide d'aller acheter à manger il
retourne chez lui et là en regardant par
la fenêtre
qu'est ce qu'ils voient bah la vidéo
sera plus explicite que mes mots
manu le fond qui le fixe
oui je l'appelais manu le faut parce que
c'est le faux manu la manul il va voir
la police ils leur expliquent ils leur
montrent la vidéo du mec qui le fixe par
la fenêtre
ils leur montrent aussi les vidéos qu'il
a prises à l'hôtel il dit regardez hier
mec qui me suivent ressemble comme deux
gouttes d'eau ça va pas on dirait mon
[ __ ] de clown c'est flippant la police
le regard bizarre le crois pas du tout
alors il décide de rentrer chez lui en
rentrant chez lui sa poignée elle a
changé c'est une porte qui s'ouvre avec
une clé et manu il dit [ __ ] j'ai le
souvenir de l'ouvrir avec une carte
d'hôtel mais c'est impossible parce
qu'avant d'aller voir les policiers
j'étais chez moi et en rentrant chez moi
j'ai dû ouvrir la porte mais j'ai pas la
carte de l'hôtel elle est resté à
l'hôtel la barre en vacances alors
comment j'ai fait pour l'ouvrir en
rentrant la première fois il commence à
péter un câble contre manu [ __ ] ils se
décident à retourner à l'hôtel en
vacances parce qu'ici qui va rien
résoudre chez lui et que le truc le suit
et l'on ne peut plus alors ils réservent
un vol le lendemain pour repartir à cet
autre hôtel et en voulant partir ils
n'arrivent plus à trouver sa porte
d'entrée il se met à chercher sa porte
d'entrée chez lui la trouve plus il peut
plus sortir de l'arrêt il reçoit un truc
bizarre c'est comme si tout était plus
grand mais plus petits à la fois c'est
le même endroit mais tout n'est plus au
même endroit par rapport à avant d'un
coup il trouve enfin une fenêtre il
regarde par la fenêtre et il voit la
piscine de l'hôtel
alors qu'il est chez lui il est rentré
chez lui il décide de tweeté une photo
de ça pour nous prouver qu' un truc qui
va pas sauf que sur la photo nous on
voit juste sa rue on voit pas du tout la
piscine la manyu dit qu'il entend
quelqu'un chez lui il pense qu'il est
pas tout seul il réussit à se réfugier
dans une salle de bains elle ressemble
pas à sa salle de bain c'est un autre
endroit c'est un mélange entre la salle
de bains de la chambre de l'hôtel et sa
salle de bain lui le faux manuelle ou la
porte de la salle de bains regarde
manuel quai au sol sans bouger y
comprends pas ce que l'autre manuelle
veut il bouge plus et réaliste qui n'a
aucune solution à son problème que il va
y passer mais que peut-être il peut
prévenir le prochain locataire de cette
chambre d'hôtel alors il décide de
sortir son stylo et trouver un endroit
où marquer un message d'avertissement
que seul le prochain locataire pourra
lire et il trouve où il pouvait marquer
ce message l'histoire recommence encore
et encore
et là il écrit un message avec la même
manière dont s'exprimer le mec était
rentré dans la chambre de manu pour la
première fois les mots sont pas dans le
bon ordre
c'est bizarre merci pour tout j'aurais
aimé ne jamais me rendre à cet hôtel si
seulement j'avais écouté avant le
message de peut-être que j'aurais été
sauvés
au petit débrief pour ceux qui ont pas
trop réussi à suivre comme un taux
compris ou peut-être parce que j'ai mal
expliqué je sais pas cette histoire elle
est dure à raconter parce que là on
parle pas juste de preuve qu'il ya un
esprit qui te hand ce qui est assez
classique un paranormal activity conjure
in tout ça on connaît cette histoire lot
d'esprit de possession démoniaque là
c'est différent en fait c'est comme si
un mec simple relais à strangers in
c'est comme si un mec s'étaient
retrouvés bloqués entre plusieurs
dimensions vous savez il ya plusieurs
dimensions plusieurs réalités c'est à
dire je vous l'avais déjà dit rhdp dans
une vidéo je crois théorie du complot
par exemple dans une autre réalité je
suis boulanger dans une autre réalité
vous êtes agriculteur du coup on suppose
simplement que manu est restée bloquée
entre deux réalités c'est pour ça que
l'espace arrête pas de bouger autour de
lui et que c'est toute ma nuque il a
aperçu prendre sa glace aller faire les
courses et bien c'était juste lui le
premier jour en fait
et l'histoire se répète en boucle manu
arrêt pas d'apercevoir manu assez génial
mais j'ai pas tout expliquer je vous
laisse débattre sur ça dans les
commentaires mais perso je trouve que
cette histoire elle est géniale sachez
que c'est une histoire c'est comme un
film mais au final servian même
l'histoire est tellement bien raconté il
ya des photos il ya tout ce qu'il faut
pour y croire c'est magnifique on s'en
fout que ce soit vrai ou pas je trouve
ça génial 2018 pour ça il ya une
nouvelle manière de raconter des
histoires et que ce soit vrai ou pas à
l'arrivée on ressent des choses et on
est content d'avoir lu ça n'hésitez pas
à m'envoyer des histoires comme ça si
vous en trouvez peut-être que j'en
expliquerait d'autant vidéo j'avoue moi
j'ai un penchant pour les histoires
d'horreur là c'est entre les deux c'est
angoissant mais c'est pas de l'horreur
haute gâchée toile ça vous aura plu
n'hésitez pas et même de c'est le cas je
vous dis à très vite je veux pas rentrer
un scout j'me chie dessus je vais
prendre un bruit baer allez à bientôt
[Musique]